this video is sponsored by curiosity
stream use the link in the description
to start watching thousands of
documentaries and get access to our new
educational streaming service nebula at
no extra cost one week every year either
in January or February Chinese train
stations bus terminals roads and
airports overflow with travelers Chinese
New Year is the largest human migration
on earth with nearly 400 million people
returning home to their families
for comparison Thanksgiving sees 50
million travelers the auto buying
pilgrimage 40 million and India's Camela
30 rather than give workers a yearly
allowance of paid leave Chinese
factories and companies shut down
completely for two weeks of the year
around the Lunar New Year and National
Day these golden weeks test the limits
of China's world-class transportation
network many of the country's
notoriously high toll fees which are
normally designed to disincentivize
driving are suspended creating 40
kilometer or 25 mile traffic jams train
and plane tickets sell out in minutes
prices skyrockets and then the
celebrations begin kids receive lucky
red envelopes filled with cash incense
is burned for ancestors and fireworks
light up the sky in 2019 the year of the
pig it was celebrated with giant statues
in malls parade floats billboards and in
Hong Kong pig nose shaped fireworks the
only things missing were actual pigs in
the last two years a third of China's
pigs have died in the largest ever
animal disease outbreak causing pork
prices to more than double now losing
such a large source of food would be
disastrous
anywhere but for the largest pork
consuming country on the planet under an
administration whose power hinges on its
ability to raise the standard of living
during a trade war with the country who
supplies its pig feed is a crisis some
consider more dangerous for Beijing than
the Taiwanese presidential elections the
and Huawei or even the Hong Kong
protests pigs are the ideal farm animals
they don't require much space they bear
about 12 piglets twice a year and they
eat just about anything because of this
they've long been an important part of
the Chinese diets but not for the reason
you might expect Mao Zedong called pigs
fertilizer factories on four legs
ordering they be fed leftover household
scraps to produce high nutrient manure
which would in turn produce higher grain
yields so while nearly every family
owned pigs eating pork was a rare luxury
reserved for holidays like the New Year
today pork is still seen as a luxury but
one that everyone now expects about half
of the world's pork is consumed in China
and that's not just because of its large
population adjusted per capita China
Hong Kong and Macau eat the fourth most
pork in the world even more impressive
that's despite China's sixteen thousand
eight hundred and seven dollar per
capita GDP compared to third place the
European Union's 41,000 ninety one
dollars pork accounts for two-thirds of
all meat consumed in China with poultry
accounting for 21 percent beef eight
percent and lamb five but even these
numbers don't adequately explain the
Chinese obsession with pigs throughout
the country pork is an almost default
ingredient dim-sum dumplings rice
noodles soup even sometimes dessert
contains pork
whether it's listed on the menu or not
the Chinese word for meat roe literally
means pork all other types of meat have
to be specified cows for example are neo
so beef is Neil roe fish you becomes you
row and so on the Chinese character for
family or home SIA is composed of two
elements or radicals the character for
roof underneath the character for pay
all of this is to say pork is more than
just a meal in China it's ingrained in
the culture which is why it's outbreak
of African swine fever is so troubling
the good news is that the virus isn't
dangerous to humans the bad news is that
it's basically Pig Ebola the difference
is that Ebola isn't airborne only
remains active for a few days at room
temperature and only has about a 50%
fatality rate African swine fever
meanwhile spreads like wildfire it's
found in all the body fluids and tissues
of its victims who experience vomiting
high temperatures and difficulty
breathing some variants have a 100%
mortality rate but death doesn't stop
the virus from spreading
it lives in feces and urine for days and
can be spread through flies ticks
insects vehicles equipment or clothing
and because there's no vaccination the
only solution is to kill and bury all
infected animals as of 2019 the virus
has reached Vietnam Cambodia Mongolia
North Korea Hong Kong and every province
of China official Chinese government
sources estimate one hundred and forty
billion dollars in direct losses and the
death of a quarter of the world's pigs
although these numbers are likely
inaccurate because government subsidies
for affected farms are set below market
prices both local government officials
and farmers themselves are incentivized
to hide and under report the scale of
the outbreak regardless the central
government simply doesn't have many
options many countries keep emergency
supplies of their national obsessions
Canada has the strategic maple syrup
reserve the US has the petroleum reserve
and China since 2008 has the strategic
pork reserve comprised of live farms and
dozens of highly guarded storehouses or
packaged pork as frozen and rotated when
prices rise supplies fall or in the days
before the new year the government
releases some of its supply onto the
market the exact amount of pork is kept
as a national secret but is said to be
around
thousand tonnes which compared to the
country's demand for 50 million tonnes
every year hardly makes a difference
during a crisis of this magnitude the
government has lifted import bans tried
breeding giant pigs and some restaurants
have resorted to cooking with dog or
rabbit meat hi pork prices present
Beijing with not just an economic but
also a political problem for older
generations being able to eat a once
annual treat every day is a symbol and
reminder of their country's progress
when pork is unavailable or too costly
on the other hand it awakens grim
memories of China's dark and hungry past
while international attention focuses on
stories like Hong Kong's protests it's
easy to forget that fighting for
democracy is a privilege afforded to the
already moderately well-off for millions
of Chinese the number one concern is
putting food on the table and losing
their favourite source of protein is
more than merely inconvenient even with
reports of slowing inflation it will
undoubtedly take years for China's pig
population to fully recover in the
future China is expected to shift more
of its pig farming to large industrial
factories giving it more direct control
over their operations there's one silver
lining
however the outbreak provides a golden
opportunity for China to embrace
artificial and more sustainably grown
meat less than two percent of China's
population is currently vegetarian and
eating meat is very much part of Chinese
life so too however is tea and yet
companies like Starbucks and luck--and
coffee have seen explosive growth in
China in one survey of 30 countries 73
percent of Chinese respondents said they
would eat a plant-based meat substitute
higher than any other country including
India and China's Ministry of Health
released guidelines in 2016
recommending people cut their meat
consumption in half by 2020 no one
expects China to suddenly become the
leader in artificially grown meat but 20
years ago neither did anyone expect it
to become the electric vehicle capital
of the world or lame or high-speed rail
than the rest
the world combined or use almost
exclusively mobile payments and yet here
we are
China's authoritarian model has led to
miraculously rapid technological
progress the pig could be next there's
another story about China I'm excited to
tell but not quite ready to release I've
been working on and traveling for an
exclusive extra-long video coming soon
to nebula an educational streaming
service by some of your favorite
youtubers including Kurtz Cassatt CGP
grey Kento bento Wendover productions
half as interesting tech altar and rely
floor we've worked out a special deal
with curiosity stream so when you sign
up with my link in the description you
not only get their catalogue of
thousands of documentaries including
this series on China but also access to
nebula so you can watch many of our
videos ad free along with exclusives the
annual subscription was an already
affordable twenty dollars a year but now
with nebula it's an exceptionally good
deal and if you're quick it's just $12
for the holidays when you sign up with
my link you'll get a welcome email with
access to nebula thanks to curiosity
stream and to you for watching this
video